qui peut imaginer qu'elle va commettre
l'acte à la commis après et elle lui
fait un certain nombre de choses ça dure
en tout deux heures quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est ultra violent quoi alors ça y
est au lycée Diderot
simulant des bruits de Saintes cet acte
est évidemment négrophobe et nous
comptons sur les frères de Marseille
pour faire en sorte que ses élèves
soient sévèrement sanctionnés voilà donc
la vidéo a été partagée sur Twitter avec
cette légende oui évidemment qu'il faut
les exclure tout est choquant le black
et le plus choquant parce qu'il me
choque c'est le fait de filmer cette
vidéo et de la diffuser et je trouve ça
témoigne d'un fléau aujourd'hui qu'en
fait les jeunes pour exister sur les
réseaux sociaux sont prêts à n'importe
quoi à quoi mettre les pires horreurs et
à blesser les gens qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
dans la tête comment ils ont été éduqués
en fait c'est juste incroyable mais le
problème c'est que si on les si on les
août si on dit qu'ils sont en fait le
problème c'est que j'ai peur que après
malheureusement même s'ils sont racistes
et c'est ignoble j'ai peur qu'on s'en
prenne à eux qu'on les agresse et que ce
soit pire moi je pense qu'il vaut mieux
faire il vaut mieux peut fonctionner
mais faire de la pédagogie en même temps
en parler expliquer pourquoi ces
catastrophique parce qu'ils sont quand
même jeunes et on peut pas non plus
complètement les les excurs de la
société problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les enfants n'ont plus peur de leurs
parents qui n'ont plus peur d'émettre
des écoles qui n'ont plus peur de la
police qui n'ont plus peur de la justice
plus personne n'a peur de rien de
l'école effectivement encore une fois je
suis désolé il faut créer de la crainte
pour créer de la peur ok
en prison on les met dans un centre
éducatif fermé il faut croire je ne suis
pas il faut qu'il craignent une punition
pour qu'ils comprennent la danger
mais s'il y avait un respect de
l'autorité et qu'ils avaient peur de
quelque chose de quelque chose que ce
soit les parents ou d'autres choses
d'ailleurs mais ils n'ont plus peur de
rien ni des flics ni les surveillants ni
des profs ni de rien il y a plus de
respect et tant qu'il y aura pas de
respect il y aura des problèmes et on
attend après on va pleurer parce
qu'effectivement je te rejoins c'est là
on en rigole mais après c'est quoi c'est
une barre de fer ils se cogne dans la
rue ils sont à 7 sur une personne il y a
des drames il faut réinstaurer le
respect au sens général moi je pense à
ça comment tu fais
Benjamin Castaldi Valérie mamie
benaimont raison c'est qu'effectivement
le l'esprit pose 68 heures à gangrener
l'école il est interdit d'interdire on
peut pas mettre des mauvaises notes aux
élèves parce que aussi non ça les
traumatise ils ont plus le droit de
redoubler on sait plus quand il y a le
prof qui rentre donc petit à petit on
s'est excusé de l'autre côté
[Musique]
vendredi
à 15h15 environ Lola sort de ses cours
pour rentrer chez elle un petit peu plus
tard ses parents se rendent compte
qu'elle n'est pas rentrée s'inquiète
parce que le temps a passé et comme ils
sont gardiens de cette immeuble de
l'immeuble où ils habitent ils ont accès
à la vidéo surveillance on voit Lola qui
passe le portail elle est accompagnée
d'une jeune femme
une jeune femme sur le moment les
parents ne reconnaissent pas cette femme
comme elle n'est pas allée chez elle
qu'elle était en présence de cette femme
qu'elle ne connaissent ou qu'il ne
connaissent pas ils s'inquiète et ils
vont au commissariat qui est à 200
mètres de leur domicile centrale 19 et
ils vont signaler la disparition de leur
fille les policiers prennent ça très au
sérieux commencent à faire un certain
d'investigation dans le dans le quartier
23h15 et un SDF qui découvre dans les
parties communes de la résidence une
malle une mal en plastique recouverte
d'une couverture rouge et alors est-ce
qu'il avait l'intention de voir ce qu'il
y avait dedans peu importe bref il ouvre
cette malle et ce qu'il voit évidemment
et saisissance est un le corps d'une
jeune fille atrocement mutilé
il prévient la police enfin il sait
prévenir la police parce qu'il a pas de
portable
la brigade criminelle pour là encore
faire un raccourci arrive très
rapidement sur place et commence les
investigations et à 7h du matin ils
avaient interpellé l'auteur et trois
trois autres suspects
donc c'est Damien c'est la principale
Suisse
c'est celle qu'on voit sur la vidéo
c'est c'est elle
et c'est elle qui a reconnu les faits
voilà donc rentre du collège et là
qu'est-ce qui se passe
à 15h30 quand elle sort du collège
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle rencontre
cette elle rencontre cette
Dabia devant les devants
locataire en titre d'un appartement dans
l'immeuble de donc qui est dans la
résidence dans l'immeuble au dessus de
du domicile des parents de larmes on a
lu on a eu plein de choses qu'est-ce qui
va se passer elle arrive quand elle
l'enferme dans l'appartement de sa soeur
elle l'oblige à prendre une douche elle
va avoir des des attouchements d'ordre
sexuel à caractère sexuel et elle lui
fait un certain nombre de choses ça dure
en tout deux heures quand même elle
l'attache elle la Bayonne et c'est
d'ailleurs ce Bayon qui sera à l'origine
de sa mort puisque les causes de la mort
selon le médecin légiste c'est
l'étouffement
procès si les psychiatres estiment que
sont discernement est altéré il
prononceront l'irresponsabilité pénale
il y aura pas de procès exactement pour
la famille
l'abolition du discernement veut dire
qu'elle est soignée elle est dans les
mains des médecins de la médecine vous
rendez compte peut-être que dans 4,5 ans
il sera libéré est-ce que vous vous
rendez compte 4 5 ans ça veut dire que
les parents peuvent la croiser dans 4-5
ans dans la rue en quoi le fait d'être
fou ça change les choses en quoi ça
c'était nul à gravité Lola elle est
partie quoi qu'il arrive c'est le tueur
soit fou ou non de toute façon quand on
cuit un enfant par définition dites-moi
si vous voulez personne vous voulez
faire quoi les ampoules rétablir la
peine de mort non non
mais ils sont dans des hôpitaux fermés
mais j'ai plein d'histoires de petites
filles
j'ai condamné il ressortiront dans 10
ans vous le savez très bien
ça va durer combien de temps c'est nos
enfants
[Musique]
pourquoi on monte ces images pourquoi
BFM a montré ses images c'est juste pour
montrer que c'est personne tout à fait
normal qui met des vidéos que tout le
monde poste sur les réseaux vous rendez
compte si on avait vu ces vidéos avant
qui peut imaginer qu'elle va commettre
l'acte à la commune après Raymond
personne qui peut imaginer qu'elle est
folle toi tu penses que BFM va bien je
dis bravo BFM j'en ai marre qu'on
défende toujours à chaque fois on dit
Intel c'est fait tuer par machin on
montre le visage de la personne qui est
morte et on protège celui qui a tué moi
celui qui a tué je veux pas qu'on le
protège je veux qu'on monte son visage
je veux qu'on sache qu'ici je veux
pourrir la vie de ces gens là partout
quel âge je veux qu'on lui dise c'est
pas toi il y a 5 ans c'est pas toi il y
a 10 ans
je parle de gens je parle de gens qu'on
fait des crimes et ils vont sortir de
prison après on cache les noms de ces
gens là
tes réseaux parfois très organisés paix
le carburant et le revendre ensuite plus
cher à la sauvette ou bien via des
réseaux sociaux c'est full full full
venez
déjà courageux de venir à chaque fois ok
[Musique]
il va nous raconter un petit peu son
business mais dis donc comment tu t'es
tu t'es dit je vais vendre de lescendre
sur snap j'ai beaucoup de personnes qui
avaient qui n'avaient plus d'essence du
tout parce que moi de base je suis
dépanneur d'accord du coup j'ai eu
beaucoup de d'appels et tout du coup
j'ai essayé j'ai décidé de d'engager
deux petits jeunes de chez moi un qui
est ravitaille et un qui fait des
livraisons dans tout Paris ce qui est en
train de faire cette vidéo des cuves
pour toutes les personnes qui n'ont pas
d'argent pour le revendre à des gens qui
eux ont les moyens de passer par lui à
3,50 €50 non seulement ils font la queue
mais quand ils arrivent deux fois tu
fais la queue 2h on me dit c'est vide la
première libération que il y a des gens
qui fasse ça que directement
ou que moi je leur livre il va avoir
autant d'essence qui va être enlevé on
est d'accord c'est juste j'enlève la
circulation il y a des gens qui sont
handicapés qui n'ont pas de de moyens de
venir jusqu'à la station essence du coup
moi je
le service aux gens bien sûr moi ce qui
me gêne mon cher Medis c'est que c'est
complètement illégal et vous êtes hors
la loi et je comprends pas que on vous
laisse continuer parce que très
franchement vous risquez la prison vous
risquez une forte amende d'ailleurs je
te dis barre-toi vite parce qu'il y a le
ministre de l'Intérieur
toi tu penses que tu veux bah je viens
avec ma dépanneuse elle a besoin de 200
litres avec 30 €, je peux rien faire moi
avec ma dépanneuse
parce que tu as un mec qui a pris 200
litres j'ai un camion c'est alors tu as
une Smart j'ai un camion où est-ce que
vous trouvez autant de carburant en
dehors de France mais comment vous avez
le droit de danser
rien du tout c'est une petite entreprise
ça vous a déjà rapporté combien voilà je
sais pas si vous savez
dépannage à côté du coup je sais pas
comment office
300 litres par jour
et combien 900 euros 9 x x 3,9
exactement honnêtement vous n'avez pas
peur de la prison si vous êtes chopé
vous allez regarder en prison là
700 €.
six mois de prison et 700 € d'amende
heureusement j'ai mis du basket pourquoi
après ah parce que là non mais je te dis
en vrai peut-être il faut peut-être que
tu arrêtes de société tu vas pas courir
vraiment
la raison du tabasse une vieille dame si
tu vois tu prendras moins c'est si ça a
l'argent de l'État je vous le dis voilà
il a raison des cigarettes alcool
essence ne jouez pas que l'argent j'ai
des potes ils sont ils sont tombés en
faisant des conneries avec des
cigarettes et de là si tu veux parler de
Benjamin Castaldi
bah là pour l'instant où je vais
continuer
en direct
j'ai des personnes qui sont dans le
besoin moyen
qui était légal illégalité du quoi il
m'a dit t'inquiète je vais je vais
commencer sa phrase
merci à Nina d'être avec nous alors
vous êtes venu témoigner de la torture
vous avez subi de 6 à 9 ans avec votre
petite sœur qui n'avait elle n'avait que
deux ans de moins que vous déjà on est
on est complètement perdu puisqu'on nous
sépare de notre cocon familial de notre
mère de notre famille pourquoi vous
enlevé de votre famille on a été victime
d'un signalement on a été placé parce
que nous étions injurieuse à l'école
maternelle
on était très heureuse on ne manquait de
rien il y avait une famille aimante et
vous êtes vous êtes fait placer on est
arrivé on est rentré dans cette cette
grande maison le couple parfait avec
deux enfants on est quand même perturbé
parce qu'on perd toutes nos repères on
perd ma mère on perd notre famille on se
retrouve moi j'avais 6 ans donc j'étais
j'étais une gamine ma petite sœur 4 ans
on se retrouve à rentrer dans une maison
immense peu de temps après notre arrivée
j'entendais hurlements d'un bébé
il y avait deux enfants de quel âge
j'ai traversé tout le couloir toute la
course de la maison j'ai monté les
escaliers je suis arrivé dans la chambre
et elle était en train d'enfoncer
un bateau dans les fesses du bébé
je lui ai mis des coups de pied j'ai
craché sur elle pour qu'elle ache le
bébé et là elle m'a attrapé elle
m'emmener dans la salle de bain et
maintenant l'eau froide j'ai commencé à
appeler ma petite sœur elle m'a dit tu
veux ta soeur elle est partie la
chercher elle a ramené ma sœur elle a
commencé à noyer ma sœur à côté de moi
j'ai cru qu'on allait mourir est-ce que
le papa était là est-ce qu'il est au
courant bien sûr il était à côté d'elle
au moment où et lui il avait aucune
réaction il était
au quotidien c'était les réveils très
tôt le matin
vers 6h du matin il arrivait aussi qu'il
fasse nuit donc le matin on emmenait ma
sœur dans les toilettes pour l'étouffer
avec un entonnoir
et mettez de la nourriture dans
l'entonnoir
donc moi j'attendais derrière la porte
que ça se termine donc ma soeur elle lui
allait la mort et elle lui mettait dans
l'entonnoir la nourriture c'était des
petits pois du riz du poisson et ma
soeur elle sait tout fait et je pouvais
rien faire j'attendais pas obligé à
manger de la cervelle d'agneau cru oui
c'était les repas elle nous oblige à
manger de la cervelle d'agneau cru
qu'elle allait chercher régulièrement au
supermarché
elle nous disait ça c'est ton cerveau il
faut que tu le manges
j'allais voir la psychologue de
l'organisme de placement
que j'avais vu je lui dis ce qu'on ce
que j'ai vu sur la petite je dis ce que
nous faisait quoi qu'elle me faisait
dormir dans la cave
qu'on était qu'on mouette fin
sauf qu'elle me dénonçait j'ai prévenu
l'éducatrice il y avait le ils ont parlé
aux parents
de rentrer c'était la nuit dans la cave
et là tu sais que tu parles une fois
deux fois tu peux plus parler parce que
c'est pas possible les années plus tard
oui votre sœur vous apprenez par la
police que l'un des enfants avec qui
vous viviez en famille d'accueil qui
avait un an à l'époque avait été violée
au point d'en devenir autiste
oui on a laissé le petit bébé Arnaud il
avait 11 mois c'est à ce moment là vous
décidez d'en parler de rendre la
gendarmerie bien nous chercher
donc là il nous demande comment ça s'est
passé là-bas et puis il nous parle
rapidement d'Arnaud en nous disant qu'il
est pas bien
et c'est à ce moment-là ben moi que je
me suis effondré ma sœur elle était dans
une autre dans une autre pièce avec
d'autres gendarmes et là je répète en
fait
tout ce qui s'est passé pour nous tous
et vous vous avez des séquelles bien sûr
à vie quelles sont ces séquelles on est
claustro on a du mal à dormir
correctement la nuit on a peur du noir
on est obligé de dormir avec la télé ou
une lumière il est impossible pour vous
de manger autre chose que des liquides
alors ma petite sœur là ma sœur elle ne
peut toujours pas manger elle est
obligée de s'alimenter que de liquide
normalement
moi j'arrive à manger des trucs tout
bête quoi je vais ça peut paraître bête
mais j'arrive à manger des coquillettes
j'arrive à manger du blanc de poulet
leurs enfants vivent une vie normale
leur petits-enfants c'est pareil
leurs enfants non
ils nous ont jamais porté secours et
nous voyaient nous faire massacrer nous
faire enfermer dans la cave jamais nous
en proposer nous donner ne serait-ce
qu'un petit truc à manger on ramasser
les miels dans la voiture pour pouvoir
manger des miettes de gâteaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors anthony est avec nous merci d'être
avec nous Anthony chauffeur VTC c'était
la première fois que ça vous arrivez
première fois en 5 ans ça fait 5 ans que
vous êtes ici
tout se passe bien jusqu'à jeudi dernier
le deuxième cours de la journée et puis
[Musique]
puis elle a voulu me comment dire au
départ qu'est-ce qui se passe donc vous
allez vous chercher donc j'arrive elle
me dit qu'elle a qu'un billet de sens
c'est une course à peu près 50 euros
d'accord que je lui donne 50 euros et
qu'ensuite elle me ramène la monnaie
j'ai refusé d'accord oui donc c'est
donnez-moi 50 €, je vous ramène 100 tout
de suite c'est ça donc d'accord
donc après il monte quand même dans la
voiture elle était avec eux je vais
chercher l'argent je reviens elle était
toute seule à la base donc elle revient
avec le monsieur et au final ils veulent
pas payer je demande de payer comme
c'était une course en espèces et parce
que là on vous voit rouler oui bah c'est
au moment où je ralentis il voulait pas
payer donc j'ai dit on va on va rester
là ah oui j'ai j'ai eu peur pour ma vie
donc mon premier réflexe est de j'ai vu
des gens dans la rue d'ouvrir le carreau
et hurler et là vous avez hurler c'est
la meilleure chose à faire je pense que
ça m'a je pense que ça va bien sauvé
quand même derrière vous avez porté
plainte vous avez tout de suite j'ai
porté plainte et
les individus ont été retrouvés c'est en
cours aujourd'hui quand vous refaites
vous avez repris les courses non non
j'ai pas je compte pas reprendre tout de
suite pour l'instant je me sens pas près
de moi pour l'instant vous êtes
j'essaye de passer à autre chose et je
me sens pas pris dans l'immédia à
reprendre le boulot vous avez été très
choqué parce qu'il s'est passé je suis
franchement je suis traumatisément c'est
pas la première fois qu'ils font ça je
confirme c'est ça vous étiez au courant
oui en fait nous on a su il y a des
personnes qui se sont déclarées aussi
donc c'était le même couple avec des
fois différentes personnes et la
plateforme Bolt n'a jamais pris
l'initiative de les déconnecter donc du
coup là il y a des enquêtes en cours je
peux pas trop parler mais voilà on verra
ce qui va se passer c'est pas la
première fois qu'ils font ça non et
quand on voit ça on se dit que il y a
peut-être tout le système des VTC à
revoir parce qu'il y a de plus en plus
d'agression de chauffeurs de plus en
plus d'agressions de passagers je crois
qu'il y a de moins en moins de
chauffeurs parce que les conditions de
travail se dégradent malheureusement les
gens ne veulent rien payer ni les
chauffeurs ni les courses donc ça crée
des tensions est-ce que c'est pas tout
le modèle des VTC qu'il faut revoir
selon vous moi je vais vous répondre ça
fait des comprenez que justement je
défends secteur on a essayé faire ma
voix clairement ou je vais répondre à
votre question n'a pas eu le temps une
fois quand j'étais venu on paye une TVA
sur les 25% de la commission Aubert
est-ce que c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui
on doit payer à la place du Berre est-ce
que c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui on nous
impose une tarification on nous dit
c'est comme ça vous voulez vous voulez
pas on vous déconnecte du jour au
lendemain on nous dit que ça crée de
l'emploi non ça crée du chômage parce
que je peux vous dire qu'il y a des
personnes qui ont exercé deux trois mois
et qui sont déconnectés à tort et le
pire dans cette histoire là c'est qu'il
y a rien qui va on est dans une société
de où nous surveille parce que dans la
plateforme ce qu'on a découvert c'est
effrayant c'est que bon nous filons à
notre insu on les écoute à notre insulte
nos données personnelles par ailleurs il
y a tout à revoir est-ce que dans ces
cas-là quand vous êtes victime d'une
agression la plateforme pour laquelle
vous travaillez vous indemnise bonne
question c'est la première fois que ça
m'arrive j'attends toujours un retour de
leur part à sujet là je peux répondre
non non parce que dans les conditions
d'utilisation générale c'est une
plateforme d'intermédiation c'est pas
une plateforme qui emploie des salariés
des indépendants donc c'est
catégorique voilà au niveau de la
dashcam alors comment ça se passe parce
que vous vous aviez donc cette caméra
c'est pour ça qu'on a pu voir cette
vidéo tournée sur les réseaux vous
l'achetez ça coûte combien il y a
plusieurs modèles la mienne coûte un
petit 200 euros d'accord et à la base je
l'achète pour me mettre en sécurité
d'accord ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui et
aussi pour les accidents de la route
pour me protéger c'est quelqu'un recule
me rentre dedans dans les deux cas côté
client et côté accident routier et je
regrette pas de l'avoir d'avoir investi
et sans les vidéos je pense pas que je
serai là aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]